at 26 ali harby ali has a lifetime ahead
of him but a lifetime that will be spent
in prison let's say he's got a knife and
he's just steps up
after murdering the mp the islamist
extremist had hoped he'd get shot dead
by police
but the brave officers who arrested him
didn't have guns
sir david amos's family said they felt
no elation at the whole life
sentence a family statement was read out
by britain's top counter-terror police
officer it breaks our heart to know that
our husband and father would have
greeted the murderer with a smile of
friendship and would have been anxious
to help
how sickening to think what happened
next
it is beyond evil
the judge described sir david amos as a
man of the greatest substance his loss
he said had national significance he was
serving the public at the moment of his
murder the judge told ali the murder had
struck at the heart of democracy the
only thing in the killer's favor he said
was his lack of previous convictions but
that wasn't enough to avoid the
punishment of a whole life prison
sentence
before the murder ali had researched
other potential mp targets in statements
reading court they told of the lasting
effects on them and their families
so too did sir david's parliamentary
aide julie cushing who heard her boss
being murdered
she wrote the moment i realized sir
david had died when the paramedics
stopped running and the crime tape went
up is always running through my mind
the expression on the perpetrator's face
as he walked out with the police has
stayed with me all the time as he looked
so smug and so self-satisfied
after the sentencing the debate over mp
security continued we have to have a
balance between looking after mps and
preserving democracy
but at the same time making sure that a
representative is always available to
his constituents as a teenager concerns
that ali was a potential extremist were
not pursued
police have reiterated appeals for
information about any individual
considered at risk of becoming
radicalized
martin brunt sky news of the old bailey